at this point when you're getting a 50
000 purchase order are you guys are you
guys apple inc
i'm working for hewlett-packard and my
salary is 25 000. i got so scared i had
hewlett-packard sent a description of
the personal computer to every one of
their divisions and they all turned it
down but i mean are you are you when
somebody's writing a check to you and
steve
are they writing it to apple inc or
that's not even a company yet they're
just writing it to you guys that live in
palo alto um we weren't inc
this was a partnership for that apple
one phase yeah and uh and people just
loaned us money i think just
to steve wozniak or something good
friend from high school um i i we did
have a name apple
apple computer as a partnership it's
formed as a three-person partnership a
partnership partner who had 10 sold out
after a few weeks
right is it right that it's
a mystery to everybody
why it's called apple
well steve jobs one time i picked him up
the airport and we're driving down 101
or something and he said i got a great
name for the company apple computer my
first response was what about apple
records well they're a record company
we're a computer company i said that's
all it takes he said yeah
and it's funny because we lost hundreds
of millions of dollars to the kingdoms
oh you got to see the beatles and then
we got lost more huge money to the
lawyers that we sued for losing the case
um but um
no but it was just such a great name who
could ever turn that down those were the
days you didn't need to have a technical
name that said what your company does
you could be anybody it was a fun fun
loving time and on the last day of
dancing with the stars the finale when
we all came back long before before it
was going to go on the air i was sitting
up almost nobody was there and i'm
sitting up on the balcony right next to
a doctor who had treated my horrible
wound which he didn't talk about my
hamstring wound
cost me a week of practice um and i sit
next to him he said that his brother
worked on that farm was up in oregon
with steve and it was his brother that
went up to steve and said i got a great
name for your company wow that's the
real far-off truth yeah i don't know if
that's ever told
and but you believe that story that's oh
totally wow oh totally somebody no
reason to make anything up and there
weren't that many people on that farm oh
yeah um
scott said something that
would never have occurred to me but he
thought that the apple logo with the
bite taken out of it
represented uh
eve biting the apple of the tree of
knowledge
after you have something you like you
kind of say well what what are some
things that we could say about it right
so i'm sure it's been said but what
happened was mike markle put in the big
money to build a thousand computers for
the apple ii yeah he put up the money he
was a third equal partner we had three
equal partners
and he was the adult in the house he
told us how you form a company who you
hire what their responsibilities are he
was the marketing guy at the time he was
he was into marketing pushing marketing
steve jobs could never consider doing
any engineering he didn't really know
engineering he couldn't design things he
never knew what computer hardware
software was really i could get into
more stories about that but so steve
followed in the wanted to go in the
marketing direction and the business and
the speaking and learning how everybody
operates in a company but he didn't
really have there wasn't a title that he
could have yet
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]